you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Ches calm
and I'm going to play a 15-2 game here
it has been a while let's play against
computer for impossible it's a very low
rating for computer for impossible so ok
going with a fiend keto
how should I approach this I've played
the black end against this beast before
same position type and I've followed up
with d5 wondering if I could do
something different now I think I'm
still a fan of putting a pawn in the
center and you'll see what wife's
reaction is all right
okay well I'm probably just going to go
with a simple setup
one that deploys the LightSquared bishop
outside of the pawn chain let me insert
first c6 let them reinforce d5 so that
when I bring out my bishop there isn't
some quick strike with c4 Queen b3 but
forget about that white is heading for a
CC and keto okay
I feel like if I played Bishop f5 the
knight will play into e4 for d4 but know
how much of an inconvenience would that
be really
so I'm just kind of trying to decide do
I want to go to g4 or f5 if I go to g4
he'll just be shoot away with h6 and H
or with h3 and that's a desirable move
once white castles it's nice to have the
h2 square for the King let's put the
bishop on f5
okay well that's obstructing the C pawn
not to worry about any quick strike this
is my bad bishop on f5 I may still want
to take some care over my Bishop h6 is a
useful move flight square reason and it
preserves the bishop to any knight
attack I'm going to go with that
age six okay and now I'm just
whether or not I want to play Knight d7
and maybe shoot for a pawn duo or just e
six
I'm going to go with Knight to d7 let me
retain some options with my e pawn for
the moment where else is he going to go
okay let's go back this was the idea so
maybe you why it's headed for f4 no okay
you know what on second thought I think
I still want to simply go to e6 because
this night and I think white might try
to let's say coordinate a bishop and
Knight and land on the f5 square so I
want on take some some steps to guard
the f5 square let's just go eat six
computer will be making a reply it
within the just a few seconds every time
well a move like Bishop b4 must be met
with a three well I guess I move like
III could be played but Bishop b4 would
be threatening D for winning the night I
don't think I could really take
advantage of the night this a there's
ten a similar situation so pointed out
with Bishop g4 if I try Bishop b4 he'll
be challenged immediately and white is
slowly gaining some queenside space so
I'm just kind of trying to determine
where I want to go with my dark square
bishop
these three yeah which one of these
three do I really want to go to
I feel like this might be quite all
right
I'm hesitant to go to d6 because I'm
anticipating an e4 advanced and I want
to kind of steer clear of any fork
possibility with e5 this feels more
modest but I think it's just fun Bishop
c5 to try to provoke a d4 is another
idea then a white would have a harder
time playing efore I'm just kind of
about trying to anticipate what type of
pawned advances White's going to go with
how will this position open up in other
words
hanging off of d6 so c5 e 7
let me just go here see if I could maybe
provoke d4 okay
probably Castle you know let's just
Castle I thought for a moment about
forming a battery it's a very odd move
rook from a closed file I mean there's
there's no clarity just yet with
no open files just yet so I'm not
thinking about moving any of my rooks
right now maybe I could make a pretty
non-committal move keep my central
structure as is and just play a5 my
other ideas Queen e7 but I'm just kind
of going to kind of wait I guess a5 and
this white is lining up this smooth
how much I could really
maybe Queen c7 is another move
I don't know not sure how to really I'm
not sure what my candidate will desire
let's say
five
Queeny seven don't know that I
they have much more
27 to maybe get some type of peace
exchange
accomplishes this is a I mean belt
bishops are pretty good for white this
is maybe more dangerous Bishop actually
on b2 I've no pawns obstructing it and
it's striking down at my Kings side
Queen d7 Bishop e3 there is some backing
up type of move
like clean I'm just going to go with a
five this night ever moves I have this
advance okay maybe I could continue
expanding with b5 now then there's takes
I want to be able to recapture with this
pawn
I don't know I could consider capturing
going to justify the RIP move though I
think I still want to hold my ground at
this point
white seems like they're going to go
let's say King to h1 and f4 or maybe
even like a try to change the structure
with d4 and then here I don't know if I
would be afraid of that
[ __ ] c7 I feel like I'm regretting the
a5 move because it takes and then maybe
the knight jumps into d5 so it can play
this move just yet
this advance in this one I'm going to
remove my rook here
so if deformation can come back to be
eight and if my night is ever kicked if
you go back to EI and my rooks are still
connected all right let's take towards
the center now the B five squares week
and of course computer jumps right in
there
okay let's play Queen b6 throw a punch
right back
don't allow the knight to return here
where's my light square bishop he's a
long way off from trying to kick this
night away he is really well positioned
so my bishop can't challenge the knight
who's going to maybe my Knights 98 into
d6 is a way forward
first what about Bishop b4 dark-squared
bishop exchange this guy scares me my
structure does a fine job of like the e6
and d5 structure do a good job to
control these two minor pieces it's this
guy that kind of concerns me if I go for
this maneuver maybe the Queen comes over
here this is one of my best defenders of
my Kings side let's let's try this first
let's go Bishop b4 and see how white
replies okay well at least the bishop
isn't seeing along this diagonal
directly so now we're going to come all
the way back and I guess my next idea
will tribute to try to challenge this
this Knight right here that's a very odd
move starting one pin in potentially
another what's the idea behind that I
really don't know I got to move a little
bit faster she's still shooting for a c4
maybe I should play route to c8 first
before I think about these uh backward
moves maybe get one more piece involved
let's activate one more piece
see the white does okay so they're
getting the night back in the ballgame
this is another night going to return on
this square not too much I could really
do about that I think I need to at least
attempt to fight against any pieces that
arrived on this be five square and I
don't know what my knight on f6 is
really doing so let's uh let's try to at
least challenge this guy okay where's
that Bishop headed I don't know
five or okay right here I play Knight to
d6 Bishop here oh that's a that feels
like it's a problem so I may be the
knight jumping into a 696 Bishop e3
queen a6 okay I think I'll be okay there
let's get 96 in four minutes guess I
have to scoot over here it's not fun
clean is pretty sidelined yeah I thought
you might do that another night
returning on d5 okay how can I get this
like to challenge b5 I'm really
regretting my a5 decision one little gap
in my opponent is taking advantage of
that
after that
think this night needs to do something
else let's try to get into c6 what am I
missing
oh my god what am I missing
really really computer impossible that's
how you're going to play this one huh
sneaky guy so just are you smashed
through Knight takes c6 Queen takes
Knight Knight takes c6 and you take my
rook then you take here two pawns in a
rope for two minor pieces those are two
very important pawns to my center pounds
well guess what there's not much I could
really do about that is there can I
really avoid taking the knight just play
rook here oh that's really awkward but
maybe I need to do that rook here
on Queen takes bishop yeah
the Queen for a few minor pieces they're
getting pawns as well takes knight
Knight takes pawn
I got to go back to let's say a
six-night takes rook it takes Knight
Bishop takes pawn
I don't know I think I maybe
have to just allow that try to play with
this imbalance
all right they're getting two ponds and
a rook to my on my only center ponds and
now this okay
typical computer let's get my knight
back in the ball game
all right here you know
where else is he going to go okay
wanna get some some trades in also my
queen she is like way out of the
ballgame I think I want my knight on f6
Knight ei to f6 let's get a dark square
Bishop exchange in there right here
takes Queenie - that's a bit scary some
idea taking up my night and Queen to e7
[Music]
okay try my queen in the corner I'm
going to try to reroute my queen towards
the Kings side Peters still focusing in
on the
file okay maybe I
still going for this right now
I think I could do this trying to get my
knight into the f6 square I think it
will stand well there ouch
well that's painful King takes bishop
and then clean the e6
mate yeah well that's a goner then
there's not much I could do but resign
here yeah that's a backbreaker King he
ate Bishop takes Knight I'm losing
another piece
ouch man well as mentioned I it was not
too long after I played a5 that I just
started to regret that decision
I think I've referenced it just kind of
I don't know thinking yeah maybe white
will take here and jump into this Square
and and I don't know if I didn't give
enough respect to this idea but I mean
just pouncing on that be 5 square really
caused me a headache
so this a5 moon
do something else because as mentioned
you know when I play D six the idea was
to not allow any pieces into the f5
square and yeah
five but they got into b5 and that
really unmasked the bishop and this is a
really desirable move I should not have
given up that square I need to do
something different right around here
instead of a five I don't know what more
to add I'll have a quick look at it with
the computer but yeah they take and now
what do i do on the recapture I take
here I guess I could have can yeah I
could have considered taking with a
knight and why did I consider that I was
just too fixated on maintaining up or
taking towards the center and
maintaining my central pawn presence two
versus one I should still the I should
have at least considered Knight takes
pawn here huh yeah
considered Knight takes pawn here and so
maybe a five would be okay then I
recapture with the knight
if the knight captures only then I can
recapture the C pun and there isn't a
quick way at least for white to take
advantage of the b5 square so maybe I
still could do this but making a better
decision in reply to this capture yeah
okay well let's just double-check it
with the engine and see what more we
could take away from this one all right
let's see what we could do a little bit
better here the opening should just be
equal right up into that a five point is
really what I want to touch on real
quick alrighty
so not
will cease exchange for some time and
maybe spent the most time right around
here deciding on where exactly to deploy
the bishop this should be for it's okay
with I didn't really see much point in
doing that figured he would just get
kicked as mentioned with a three iCal
crook there
with a five rookie eight
another idea within e5 advanced I don't
know I I'm fearful about this kind of
stuff pulling e5 I've seen I've seen it
do this this kind of Anu ver fish of h3
and try to trade LightScribe bishops and
plant the knight in there I could always
work around it if something like this
happens a bishop on f8 is a fine job of
restricting the night looking for maybe
something a bit more comfortable playing
within a structure that's more familiar
to me and doing something non-committal
with a5 okay let's see this point right
around here after Queen e7
and truck there
did not consider at all d 492 and any
five
grabbing a little bit of space and I
give up this square but yeah I grab a
little bit of space I don't really don't
know if I'm a big fan of this
while I'll be returning with rook f1 and
striking at my centre quick even
suggesting c3 here
I guess I really wanted to play within
the structure maintain a six b5 and c6
I played rook there and after this
capture also take with the e pawn yeah I
mean I really should have given more
weight to its Knight to d5 mo so
suggesting a takes giving up this square
but at least I'm not having to work
around Knight to d5 I'm I just created a
big hole in my position and I and now
the computer pounced on it so ii guess
ii takes and i think it popped up as
well knight takes is fine
how bad is he takes and i certainly give
just a little bit up okay it's not
losing but yeah I mean it caused me a
great headache as you saw 95 and already
have to be very careful with where I go
with my queen
you know that night is a really big
bother rook ac8 okay I first played that
and then backed up let's go with e5
again I get my rook playing still even
ish but man that is a great past on b5
98 it's okay with okay and
there 97 96 okay I played nine 2d6 sign
without even likes me here
bit of a shock but alright clean a six
and after that move it wants to go with
e5
think I really ever had it in my head to
to establish a pond do all I wanted to
maintain the structure and combat the
kingside fiend keto bishop mmm okay I
still had in my mind to challenge that
night on b5 somehow it takes forever but
yeah going for a little bit of a
reposition in we're pretty much with the
game's end 97 okay
yeah I see this so often by the computer
it'll it'll go in for a rook into ponds
and give up the two minor pieces maybe
it'll just be equal ish but with that in
bounds it's house I don't know so the
computer always gives you problems or
always gives me problems stuff to to
work with this imbalance
so it's still even it likes 90 d7 I went
Knight to c6 yeah it's still even okay
so when was it just losing just that
final move it doesn't like showing the
clean in the corner once you go it's b6
well that's a really scary move to make
b6 I guess on takes I'm taking with the
rook and then I'm defending the knight
okay with my clean in the corner trying
to sneak over in fight and now this is
just a losing move next trying to get
into f6 yeah complete blind spot to this
little tactic on f7 well fairly equal
true out um I don't know I was really
blind too
I didn't really appreciate to be 5
square and how annoying that that could
be just no no it seemed like such an
equal position and then give the
computer one little inch and the pieces
start jumping into my position like this
and I'm struggling to just try and get
rid of that night it was uncomfortable
for me but in the computers I is still
equal right to the end here
I don't know if I could do it different
I should really think more about
changing the structure possibly going in
for 'if I've not maybe I shouldn't have
been too concerned about a knight
arriving on the f5 square so getting
back to this point right here this
capture maybe it's simply quite alright
to take like this and okay it's really
such a big deal a piece dropping into f5
I don't know yeah I don't think it
should be too much of an issue for me
but I was too too fixated on maintaining
a certain structure and that left me
blind to some other possibilities as you
saw okay well as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and I will catch
you in the next one and it's all for now
take care bye
you